Hello everyone, this is Frank Defradis, and I'm here with a special report before the regular program starts.
The program has been produced for a few days, and in fact has been up on the web for a day already.
But I wanted to get this out to you as quickly as possible, so I'm tagging this on to the beginning.
I went out to pick up some food tonight, and when I was waiting for it to be made, there was a little flyer that was on the counter from Eckerd Drugstore, which is a chain of drug stores.
I believe it's a national chain.
I know it's owned by JC Penny, and since JCPenney is a national department store, I'm assuming that Eckard is a national chain of drug stores as well.
So I'm paging through this flyer and I see a laser pointer on sale for $7.99.
Now, as you may remember, a few weeks ago, one of the Holo Talk listeners, Steve Michael, came on the show and he told us about his work producing laser holograms using a laser pointer, a $49 laser pointer that he picked up at Edmonds Scientific.
He sent me two of the holograms, a laser transmission hologram and a reflection hologram, and they were beautiful.
So I was going to go down to Edmonds tomorrow, which is Monday, and take up one of these $49 laser pointers until I had a chance to see this ad.
Now this $7.99 laser pointer is called the Bullet Beam Laser Pointer.
It's manufactured by a company called Vector Manufacturing, and it is 5 milliwatts, it is 650 nanometers in wavelength, and it runs on three LM44 1.5 volt batteries, which totals out at about 4.5, or exactly 4.5 actually.
Now here's what here's the exciting part of this.
A lot of people think that you should get as close to the wavelength of the helium neon laser as possible to do holograms.
But actually, with ACFA materials, if you were to ever look at their specification sheet and the response curve, the ACFA materials are actually more sensitive to the deeper red part of the spectrum than they are the part of the spectrum that the laser uh helium neon laser produces.
So it's not necessary to be close to 633 nanometers.
What you need is the coherence length of the diode itself.
Now, apparently this diode that Steve Michael bought has a lot of coherence to it because he's produced very deep holograms.
Now, whether this one does or not, I don't know, but I'm going to find out.
I actually bought two of them.
One I'm going to run off the batteries, and the other one I'm going to run off of a Radio Shack power supply here, which I notice I do have a 4.5 volt setting on it, so that I will never have to buy batteries again.
I'll just run it off of house current.
And I'll tell you what, if I find out that I'm doing a hologram with this $7.99 laser pointer, I am just going to be jumping up and down three o'clock in the morning.
I'll tell you, it's going to be absolutely fantastic.
There's quite a bit of excitement about laser pointer holography ever since that uh news broke on Holotalk a couple weeks ago.
And it's fantastic.
Why go out and spend $800 for a laser when you can get one right now, I'm holding in my hand for $7.99.
It's just going to revolutionize holography in this country.
Not at the upper end at the research end, obviously, but at the end where you've got your amateur and hobbyists and people who have always wanted to do holograms but never had the uh resources to go out and spend $800 or or so for a laser and uh uh optics and all this other kind of stuff.
So in any case, this is my report for the week.
I'm going to go into the lab and start experimenting with this laser diode, and I will come back on next week and let you know what the report is.
If I do not have any luck with it, I'm going to run down to Edmonds and pick up the same one that Steve Michael has, which operates, I believe he said it's operating at 640 nanometers.
But I don't think the wavelength should have anything to do with it.
The AgFlick materials actually peak at around 710 to 720 as I sit here and look at the graph, the curve.
And 633, it begins to rise in sensitivity from that point until it reaches its peak right after the 700 nanometers.
So if you've got a 670 nanometer laser diode, even though it's dimmer to the eye than the 633, it's still received better by the emulsion on Agha materials.
You've got less of an exposure time because it's more sensitive to that part of the spectrum.
So here's this week's show.
Rob Taylor is the guest.
He's from Fourth Dimensional Holographics, and I'll be back next week with a report.
Take care.
The following is a production of Frank Defratis and the Internet Legend of Holography.
Hello, everyone.
This is Frank Defratis, and welcome to HoloTalk for the week of December 7th, 1998.
My guest this week is Rob Taylor, owner of Fourth Dimension Holographics in Nashville, Indiana.
Rob will be filling us in on what's hot this holiday season with holograms, along with a few new directions his gallery and retail shop will be taking, such as his new holographic portrait services.
Next week I am going to replay the Steve Michael interview due to several requests, one of which is the publication Holography News, which is going to publish the announcement of the program running.
So this will give their subscribers an opportunity to log on and listen.
As you may remember, Steve is creating holograms using a standard out-of-the-box laser pointer.
And I have to tell you, the excitement about this has not yet died down at all.
I'm going to be taking some time for the holidays and family, so HoloTalk will be off the air with new programs until we pick it up again for the week of January 10th, which will then take us all the way through to Memorial Day at the end of May.
So what I'm going to do is go through this season's archives, which aren't yet available on the archive page, and grab a few shows, maybe from the beginning of this season in September, and rerun them over the holidays.
So let's move on to the Rob Taylor interview.
As usual, I'm not going to come back on after the interview, so I will thank you now for tuning in.
Also, I'd like to wish all HoloTalk listeners a happy holiday season from our house to yours, and hope that it is filled with the love of friends and family.
Hello to my daughter Faith, who is away at college as a physics major.
Looking forward to having you both home in two weeks.
Also, daughter Renee, who helps me around the studio, which I really appreciate since it's just as much time, work, and resources to do this show as it is any weekly radio broadcast.
And of course, my wife Debbie, and we're coming up on 25 years, baby.
Love you all.
Okay, folks.
Here's the Rob Taylor interview.
I'm out of here.
We should really start off by you telling us a little about the gallery that you have in Nashville, Indiana, how it got started, um we um opened a a l our little holo shop about eight years ago and uh eight hundred square foot area, uh a a commercial space in Nashville, Indiana and Nashville is kinda unique because uh most of Indiana's relatively flat in a farmland and uh where we're located is uh kinda in the heart of the Hoosier National Forest in southern Indiana and uh Nashville has uh the largest state park uh in Indiana and so we're a small rural uh community but uh we also have a a very big tourist based economy and there's a lot of uh uh shops and uh crafts people and things and count.
We get maybe two or three million people through Brown County, that's the county that Nashville's located in a year.
So it's uh works out well and we decided to put a hologram gallery shop in uh and it's worked out real well.
Uh this we had uh like I said, we opened it up about eight years ago.
About we uh actually uh put a studio in the back of our shop and we had a uh four by eight foot hand table and we uh spectrophysics one twenty five laser and feeling the own laser and we were doing some production of mastering and uh uh silver halite work.
But just this summer we closed both the uh older studio and uh the uh our old shop and moved to a seventeen hundred square foot space and wow got a good opportunity to move into it and uh so we expanded and uh it's all it's worked out real well now we haven't opened up our new studio yet but uh the uh the museum and the gallery and uh the shop are all open and it's it's working out real nice for us.
We've got a lot more space and and uh before we were always kind of cramped and we've got more room and can uh display some real nice holograms more aesthetically and it's it's worked out real well for us.
What made you decide to get involved with retail holography out of all the things that funny thing too about uh back in uh about ten, twelve years ago I lived in Dallas, Texas and I had a carpet cleaning company.
We were doing real well in in Dallas and uh I uh sold that carpet cleaning company and uh I have a wife and two children.
They were real young at the time and uh you know when you have two kids it your priorities start to change and I wanted to get back to my native state where I was born and uh uh raise my kids in a in a small rural community like I was raised and uh so we decided to move back and um I was looking for something to do and I'd always been interested in holography.
I majored in fine arts photography and college and so holography had always been a fascination of mine and so when we were about ready to leave we happened to come upon a gallery in uh Dallas.
Uh they still are there, I believe it's called elusive image.
Yes.
And uh that was uh really the f what gave me the impetus to start the uh shop in uh Nashville.
So we went ahead and just went ahead and opened up our shop and uh I guess you can say the rest of the system.
Now you're not just involved with selling holograms on the wall.
From what I understand you're actually a dealer with some of the newer holographic recording materials as well, is that right?
Yeah, uh-huh.
Um just uh July of this year we were given the opportunity to uh become a US distributors distributor of uh the Slavic holographic materials that are made in Russia.
And uh that was real exciting for us because uh with the uh demise of the ag so materials um we really believe that the Slavic material is gonna be the material that takes eventually takes the ag up Ag Fo's uh place and we think they make a really good holographic material and uh so yeah since July we've been a US distributor for them.
And in addition to that we we're also distributors of uh about six six different uh manufacturers of display holograms besides our own stock image line we have uh we represent about six different manufacturers so yeah that that's it we're we're real excited about that too.
Are you working with the Slavic materials now?
Um currently no we don't have our studio open when and we closed our studio when we moved to our new space.
So uh we're not using any of it right now.
Uh when we open our new studio next year, uh spring or uh early summer of next year we'll be definitely using the Slavic material.
That's going to also be a um holographic portrait studio, right?
Yeah, uh huh, yeah.
We're real excited about that also.
It's uh uh it seems like everything's coming at the same time.
But I've been working for a long time.
I've always been interested in pulse philography and uh uh been watching the technology develop as uh we've been uh in the holography industry.
And uh there's a company in uh Lithuania called Geola that makes a uh pulse laser camera system and uh January of this year I went to visit them in Lithuania and uh we've actually trained on the camera system and actually helped them put together the finishing cosmetic touches and some of the final uh optical arrays and the camera system uh of the first uh prototype uh that they have for sale.
Uh it was really, really interesting for me to it was not just only the trip itself but uh being able to go over there and uh experience it because I they're really on the cutting edge of uh pulse telography.
They're using the the new neodymium uh Yelp technology lasers, so uh for uh imaging.
It's really a really uh good uh green wavelength of laser light to work with.
And that basically just sits on a desktop too, doesn't it?
No, it's uh it's on an optical table itself.
Um probably about three by six foot, I would guess is the optical table that's mounted on.
Um it's uh the laser itself is a two joule laser and um then you have outside the actual camera system itself there's uh you know, uh various mirrors and uh mounted to tripods to give you your path links and for your both your mastering and your copying nodes.
What materials do you hope to shoot these holograms on?
The Slavic?
Yeah, we'll be using exclusively Slavic material when we get that camera system.
Just because we're distributors, there's really not a lot of choice anymore for as far as holographic emulsion.
I mean there's uh German uh material and there's uh China material but other than that there's not really much in to choose from I was on your website which is a great site.
You have a a shot on there that I love which is a two channel animated shot of young studio doing a an exposure.
I love that.
That was the old studio that was our continuous wave studio that we had running and uh you know that was just taking the one with the lights on and uh photograph of the lights on and then one with the drawing and lights on.
What would some of the listeners find when they go to your website?
Why don't you let the listeners know what what all you have there?
Uh on the website itself?
Yeah.
Well basically lists um all our different services.
Um you know it tells about our gallery and our um uh retail store um kind of lists some of the holograms, the top twenty-five holograms that we sell there.
Um we also uh sh have a uh website uh web page that goes to the uh our Slavic uh distributorship site so that the people can find out about the different um technical specifications.
Then we also are kind of uh advertising or premiering our uh pulse telography studio that we are going to have up and around the next uh spring.
So those are basically the different uh categories that we're trying to uh advertise on our web.
I put that web page, I designed the web page uh earlier this year and then actually uh uh high school senior from the local school actually did the code writing and everything for me.
Did a real good.
Now do people order holograms from you, retail holograms?
Oh yeah we uh we take orders over the phone and through the internet all all the time and we ship if not every day, probably every other day and uh especially right this this time of the year, you know uh it seems like this is our busy time of the year as far as the retail store.
Um a lot of people buy holograms for gifts people that they can't figure out what else to get 'em.
What is hot for holography this year?
As far as display holograms are out?
Oh, let's see.
Well, um what's happening the Jesus stereogram is the there's a uh that's always been a hot seller, especially right around Christmas time.
And uh the uh the Star Trek series, both the old prismatic Star Trek series and uh the Lightrix uh Star Trek series, those are always been good sellers.
Um let's see there's uh the Lightrix makes a really good line of photopolymer holograms and they're really bright and efficient holograms and they do do quite a few different ones and they're they're all real good sellers like they're birds of prey, they have a uh three channel hologram of a hawk and an eagle and an owl that's a good seller.
Uh they do one of uh Dracula, the Brahm Stoker's Dracula and also a three channel showing the three different transformations of the face.
Um generally any uh holograms most of the holograms that we sell would be within the forty to a hundred dollar range I would say uh most of them.
Also uh Derek Galen up in Canada has this new line of of uh holograms called Red Star holograms and he's uh his have been moving real well like he has a paleoon and uh uh uh a beer bottle, a Heineken beer bottle that one does pretty good.
Now he's producing these up there?
I believe he is yeah that's Royal Holographic Alley.
Yeah.
Do you have any fine artwork there from any of the uh holographic artists?
Yeah, um let's see we've got some uh John Kaufman pieces those are real nice ones.
Uh I've got uh a lot of uh pulse holograms from Ron and Bernadette Olson.
They do some really really good pulse holography.
They have a uh to my knowledge the only other uh neodymium based pulse technology for holography here in the United States.
Are the is that the series that was produced by Hughes?
Um well those were done on photopolymers with uh Hughes as you probably know is no longer they're gone uh in the holographic end of it so uh most of those are have been sold.
I have a few photopolymers left but not very many.
Those are those are really good sellers because because they were on photopolymer that you could reduce the cost of them and they really sold real well.
Unfortunately there's just not a lot of uh people to be able to produce on photopolymer anymore and so uh Ron and Bernadette's are are all on uh glass plates right now.
Oh either using Slavic uh glass plates or uh the uh Ag Fa uh Milamask plates that's used for uh photolithography.
Hmm that's interesting.
We've got some uh pieces that we just got on loan from other people uh that we you know don't sell that we just put in there as uh for the uh the kind of like our little mini museum that we have here.
Um we've got uh uh a large laboratory microscope that was done by HoloCon and that was given to us on Wednesday uh HoloCon.
Uh we have a uh portrait of uh Ronald Reagan and we have a portrait that portrait was done by Holocon Ponce McCoggan.
Uh that one I believe is the only US president's ever been recorded in a hologram.
I think Jeffrey Murray was actually doing copies for that.
Yeah, I think he was I think he had uh a few for sale I don't know if he's if he's still selling those or not but that was a really lucky thing for us to get because um you know the value of those will just continue to go up.
Yeah now do you own that Holly Martin.
Yeah.
That's down in the National Gallery.
Yeah uh yeah so um and we've also got uh some true full color holograms done by Ponce Picogan again.
Uh we've got about uh eight or ten of those.
Uh some of his uh experimental plates that were just as uh uh different subject matter where he was using uh a pan chromatic uh plate and three different lasers and being able to record uh static objects and that was a continuous way of set up and those are real nice.
I we actually sell some of those uh plates.
Well for anyone who maybe in the area of where your shop is located, why don't you give uh some information as far as your hours of operation and different things like that for the holiday season.
Oh okay, sure.
Um well we're generally open from uh ten until five during the week and then on the weekends, uh like Friday and Saturday, our hours are extended in the evening till about seven generally.
Uh Sundays we usually rent till about ten to five.
In uh January and February season because of us being in in a kind of a remote area, there isn't a whole lot of tourism.
So generally we have in the past always closed for those two months.
And I probably foresee doing that again in the uh this year, especially January because I'll be in Lithuania for the last half of the month.
So we probably won't be open much in January.
But in March we open back up to a normal business hour.
And you're hoping to have your pulse telography studio up and running by s late spring, early summer?
Correct.
Uh huh, yeah.
We're going uh in January, uh my laser engineer and I are we're going uh I think it's the eighteenth of January and going back to to see the folks at Geola and actually get this thing wrapped up and uh hopefully we'll be the uh first company in the United States to actually have one of their JPE X J systems and so we'll be a a representative for them and uh hopefully you know, be able to be up and operational by uh like I said, late late summer I mean early summers uh as our goal.
Any estimates on what it would cost to have someone come through the door and have a portrait done at this point in time?
Yeah, we're uh we've got a targeted price and this is kind of a uh a breakthrough here, but uh we have a targeted price of being able to do it for uh four hundred and ninety five dollars.
We're going to offer for one subject to be recorded on a twelve by sixteen inch glass plate and they'll get a uh you know the reflection copy on glass.
Uh that's a a considerably price reduction over any holographic portraiture that's been done in the past.
So it's uh it's a pretty neat thing to be able to offer it at that price and we hope to uh really do well at it.
So will you keep the master or will they get the the uh no we would keep the master but uh they would be able to get the uh uh white light reflection copy and uh another thing that's key to it is that it it would be a same day service.
The thing that's unique about Geola's uh JPXJ systems is that you can uh actually go from uh mastering to copying mode with just a flick of a switch.
It's a really neat thing.
I mean you know normally where you'd have oh probably four to eight man hours of of uh time involved in realigning optics and and uh going from uh uh mastering to copying mode.
Uh they've uh automated it to where it's just actually a flick of a switch and it's uh a matter of seconds.
That's great.
It's really, really a and and a neat time to be involved in pulse telegraphy because I believe pulse holography is really the wave of the future for uh display holography.
Not only can you record anything that a continuous wave holography setup can r record, but you can also record, you know, living objects.
Um if you can actually uh catch the shutter at at the right time and trigger it right you can actually stop a bullet in midair, you know, trick of a a pulse.
Any final closing comments you'd like to make for the whole talk listeners before we close out.
Oh no just wanna thank you for uh you know asking me to be on the show.
I know uh uh I listen to your Holo Talk show oh almost every week and uh your website is uh a real valuable resource to me too.
Particularly your links page.
Your links page is just quite extensive and uh philography related companies and uh information and I use that real frequently.
Yeah that's that's all I have left now.
I um I completely took the rest of the site down.
All I have is gonna be Holo Talk on the link page now.
Well that's not the kind of one to talk to you about because I think you know n your next your next uh endeavor should be uh actually publishing like a monthly um newsletter or uh uh Zion over the internet.
And there's very few people anymore that I mean there's no resources for the holography industry in general to be able to uh look at besides uh well holography marketplace and holography news is about it anymore.
And especially the art community, the holographic artists uh they don't have a voice or a medium to be heard on.
You know, that would be a a uh neat thing to be able to do is actually, you know, publish something online like on a monthly uh interval and be and you know, have subscribers on it.
What do you think?
Could be.
I generally try to do that with this show.
Did you catch the uh last week's show with Steve Michael where he's doing the holograms with the laser cleaner?
Isn't that something?
Uh-huh.
I did I didn't ever think it was possible.
You know, uh you you hear about it not being possible so no one ever tries it.
Yeah.
Uh someone like that uh ends up trying it.
His holograms are really nice.
Really?
I mean I looked at his website and uh uh the the holograms that he has displayed there is really nice.
Yeah.
All right, Rob, well, thank you very much for being on the show.
Well thank you.
And good luck for the holiday season and coming on and telling us uh what was hot.
And I'd like to encourage the uh Holo Talk listeners to go over to the fourth dimension holographics website and check out what they have over there.
And uh talk to me again, okay?
Okay, sounds good.
Thanks, Brian.
Hold on a second, I'll pick up the phone after I uh get the headphones and everything off.
Okay.
Okay, bye.